good to see you gang the boys are
planning the ru garbage 2024 tour and we
want to know where you want us to come
yeah so click the link in the
description let us know what cities you
want us to come to we're coming to all
the ones we've been to before and we're
adding a bunch new ones we just need to
know where to go so click the link let
us know and we'll see you out there gang
stay at your house welcome to another
exciting edition of are you garbage the
show where you find out if your favorite
comedians are classy individuals or or
absolute trash now here are your hosts
Kevin Ryan and H
Foley hey everybody out there and
welcome back to everybody's favorite
podcast this is R you garbage oh yeah
it's that little show we sit down with
your favorite comedians and we find it
after to gr it to be classy yeah to just
a big old piece of trash trash trash
trash I'm your host stage Foley coming
at you on a beautiful day we're out back
here at toies in the new edition she's
upstairs working on her studies okay as
you know Temple University she's
enrolled she's up there with her tutor
okay my co is coming at you from right
next to me all
right he is the CEO of Ru garbage he is
international businessman and
unfortunately he's my best pal in all
wide world give it up for KJ Kevin James
Ryan what up gang thanks for tuning in
as always please make sure you riew
subscribe on iTunes full video available
on YouTube as you know those numbers are
TR cooking baby cooking then obviously
the greatest website of all time and I'm
going to tell you out there
www.patreon.com garbage gang check it
out over there it's a freaking party and
how about a nice quick shout out to our
producer extraordinaire the old magic
man makes this all look good works the
ones the twos the threes and the fours
he crosses the te's and he dots the eyes
give it up for T-Bone MC scruffs Toby
McMullen everybody what up boys what up
T-Bone I'm excited we we got this guy in
here he came in like the rider in Black
real Johnny
Cash feels like we got a patch over on
our hands I feel like he's going to end
the lease if we don't if we don't make
up
laugh that's it pull the plug CIA Hitman
over here does he has like a Navy SEAL
who shows up to a base that no one that
no one wants to talk about except very
retired yeah gang the long hair ain't
lying we couldn't be more excited have
our incredibly and I mean incredibly
special guest here with us today for the
first time he is a very funny very
successful stand-up comedian and
podcaster and you might have seen him in
but not limited to you got Conan O'Brien
he has his own Comedy Central presents
WTF with Mark Maron Late Night with
James Cordon unprotected The Tonight
Show he has not one but two amazing
podcasts middle of somewhere pretend
problems he's on tour right now and his
standup specials and albums have almost
1 billion streams including 2021 12th
night and his brand new special over
there on his YouTube page mixed reviews
give it up for an absolute killer Chad
Daniels
everybodyy you so much thank you man
comics love sitting through intros oh
it's the
best the first first time we saw you
yeah you you you have been a a uh we we
both have a story about seeing you for
the first time years ago yeah years ago
we were talking to uh our good pal Mark
Norman about it it was at his show over
at Irish exit hot soup I think way back
this was probably 2015 16 maybe they
were in town Pro I think getting ready
to do a late night or something like
that tough room packed out it was hot in
there couple of goobers me and him in
the
back uh and you go up there and just
absolutely leveled a place yeah it was
it to the point talk about it all the
time to the point where it's stuck in
our head we were like who the [__] is
one we had never heard of you there was
like stories of you rolling in from like
like Minnesota or something and you're
like they're like oh is horse tied up
outside coming in like high Plaines
Drifter and you Mur and I remember you
were talking about like your kids which
is like that's not a room where Comics
that's all like 24 year-old comics of
like hey you know when you're on the
subway and you came in talked to him we
were like it was mindblowing how quickly
you turned the room to the point where
we still talk about it a lot super
excited to have you here buddy I don't
remember that so I'm like [__] lot of
might have not been me but I will take
the credit oh that was a ziz onari I
apologize that
was that's fair buddy give us the
backstory give us the origin story of
Chad Daniels where you from born and
raised Fergus Falls Minnesota okay moved
away for 10 years then moved back when I
had kids cuz my ex-wife and I grew up
together same town so we want to get
them back closer to family uh were you
guys College sweethearts you and your
you and your wife uh I've known her
since high school I'm sorry sixth grade
yeah high school went to prom no kids
all that stuff so so we had the makings
for that you know that story that perect
story and then that dumb divorce got in
the way but uh yeah so so who did that
okay um you know grew up Mom Dad till 15
they got divorced one of those deals dad
split sort of off and on then split for
good 21 is maybe okay when you were 21
okay what what they do for a living my
mom I thought you me a couple years ago
budy Let It Go you you're a grown
man my mom was uh was a bank teller for
a while and then she worked at a power
company she was like the lady you went
in and paid the bill to okay and then my
dad liquor salesman liquor sales me like
going around like to bars like hey do
you want to try this yeah it with boxes
Bo in a minivan with no seats huh that
kind of a thing it's my dream J what are
you talking about did he break did he
break anything like was he like uh was
like any records yeah 8
DUI I got goddamn qu of vodka what do
you want from me that's what I'm saying
like he he used that van for his a DUI
he put chairs in there and had a
traveling bar and just was drinking his
products no [__] [__] guy made a made a
bar in a Vans I don't need anybody I saw
this right out of the van absolutely no
was he on like uh like an absolute
dropped they're like you know smearing
off flavors or anything like that I
remember he had a Mr is it Mr
Boston I can't remember but I had this
was long time ago sound like a big
seller yeah it's uh it's
rail it's ra he had a ton of rail
stuff it doesn't say what kind it's just
Mr Boston liquor that's right you have
any Jin I don't know this this might be
some let put a little Gatorade in it
you'll be all right
all right okay brothers and sisters
little sister five years younger five
years younger small town yeah 13,000
Ferguson Falls Fergus Falls Fergus Falls
it sounds real nice man does sounds like
Anytown USA type thing what was what was
the house was it like uh single family
home so started there a lot of land yeah
started off single all of them in town
okay single family then we moved to this
really nice house got the basement it
wasn't finished got it all redone sister
and I have room down there boom
cash was coming that's when people was
like we we don't know we'll take Mr
Boston for all our
liquor there the golden Scher crazy 1997
amazing and so uh so then that that's
when all hell broke loose with your mom
and dad y but they so they were he was
they were doing good to that point where
they got the new house they got I think
so got a little money and then you know
it's the 80s so uh I once heard my mom
say that my dad uh put uh she how' she
say it put a house and two cars up his
nose oh and my sister and I were like
our dad's a
magician unbelievable never found that
rabbit but [__] the Hat really small
town Minnesota hitting the package well
because yeah he's you know he's in bars
he's got to move it and Shake ital's got
to be a man of the people to move this
Mr Boston he a sharp guy did he did he
dress good was he was yeah yeah real
slick sales real real funny dude real
honest all the time sharp yeah man all
right huh what was the uh what was the
sports situation growing up you play any
sports I did I played uh little bit of
basketball little bit of hockey football
uh I was a wide receiver until 10th
grade but they didn't throw the ball it
was a lot of running okay and so then I
quit to Box O to box cuz you're in
you're an in shaped guy yeah you're you
got a frame on you we don't have any
cameras in here great no yeah I'm super
in shape a I'm super in shape I mean
compared to the the other guys at the
table you're doing all right Chad yeah
I'll I'll take
you huh for Comics you're in very good
for a comic you're in very good shape
and uh your mom doesn't live in the same
house does she she does not okay what
was the name of the street uh West 7th
so it's weird because we grew up on West
7th Avenue and First Avenue just in case
you wanted to get lost in a town The
Avenues didn't cross-sect the the street
there there was no grids right no no no
it was just wonky lot of streets named
after trees that kind of town Sycamore
all that kind of yeah Maple Ash Oak all
right sounds like a nice place what was
uh what were the family vacations like
growing up anything big yeah everybody
so my mom's side my dad's side was kind
of a [__] show so so my mom side but
they're all there in the surrounding
areas yeah okay yep um my my mom's side
it was it was Grandpa Grandma and then
my mom had two brothers okay and they
both had two kids okay and so it was
we'd all go off together nothing nothing
crazy I mean I remember a
drove somewhere in a van for a very long
time I can't remember maybe maybe
Florida I don't know Florida but uh but
I was real young then and then we kept
it dad had a reup yeah I got to go meet
the Colombians in Miami holy
[__] can't take this on a plane man down
to Florida so camping stuff like that
were you guys Outdoors lake houses are
big up there or any of that we didn't we
didn't have that and that's like a
that's a thing with me is that was my
number one goal was to get a l in my
life is to get a lakeh housee and so got
that checked it off checked it off still
got it still got it no kidding y pretty
good yeah so decided to do that but uh
that was something that you know all my
friends had grown up and so I would like
to do that you asked me a question I
completely uh there was something about
uh camping camping yeah so I went
camping once with my dad it was for Boy
Scouts and it was a wind wind and
rainstorm and completely knocked our
down but no one else's and we were in
the middle of the tents so somehow he
[__] it up so badly and he's like well
hey hey're look at us working as a team
I'm like I'm freezing right now give me
a bump of Mr Boston so I can warm it up
a little that Hooch baby you got the van
here any trips to the Wisconsin Dells
not when no not when I was a kid but uh
as an adult I've been to some Bachelor
parties there which mistake out there
that's like their famous uh is that like
what that that Lake in Texas where
everybody goes no no it's there's like a
water park it's an amusement a lot of
water parks yeah there's like uh you
guys know Pete Lee yeah we know Pete Lee
very well so Pete used to do uh Barefoot
skiing he was like the guy that you'd go
watch in the Wisconsin doves what what I
know oh I'm have you seen him before you
met him did you no no no I mean maybe I
don't know but I met him yeah I met him
when we started comedy together but uh
yeah it was um so hearing about it's
funny when you see Pete and I know but
he's always like well I don't know
use my girlfriend shampoo it's like
you're a black belt
dude wait he can water ski Barefoot oh
Barefoot he's he's a crazy good
skateboarding all that stuff really very
good that's kind of the local
entertainment up there wi absolutely
Pete Lee Pete Lee water ski holy [__]
put the squirrel sick they s Pete Le
yeah and then funny too that sucks right
normally you grow up with that talent
and you're like ah forget it I don't
need into personality place was a water
park that that did Bachelor parties
imagine like the Jersey Shore kind of
there's a lot of different uh there's a
casino down there's a bunch of is it on
some type of water it's on a bunch of
water bunch of different it's not just
one thing there's Lakes yeah there's
like four water parks a casino wiconsin
Dells is a town it's like a destination
yeah all right that sounds pretty
trashy okay and how old were you when
you got your
passport oh [__] maybe in my 30s whoa
yeah where were you going Italy okay
yeah well for work or for vacation for
vacation the thing is with me it's like
you didn't need a passport most of my
adult life you know I turned 18 and 93
you didn't need a passport till
September 12th 2001 really you could
just travel with your driver D what you
could well I mean the only places I went
Mexico and and uh Canada so no kidding
yeah all you needed was a license at the
border that's a real dirt bag thing to
know
I don't want the federal government want
anything else how about the grades in uh
in school how were you 2.3 2.3 that was
your high school GPA you know your GPA
well yeah it's that bad you remember
it when when you have a bunch of people
going you're out of 2.3 sure when it's
getting screamed at you and your Tank's
pierced what the hell's going
on how about the
SATs uh you do the acts out there well
here's this is I'm going to tell you
which one is the hundreds score and
which one is the 20 score Act is the
lower is like the double digit
number I did the acts okay Midwest
typically does acts do you know what you
got 24 out of 36 that's not good that's
bad that's not great that seems pretty
good I thought it was all
right just his world's crumbling around
this this whole time he thought I think
it's not great think 2.3 and I got a 24
I mean I'm a great test it is above
average the average is a 19.5 oh okay oh
everybody
sucking my apologies Mr Daniels and did
you go to college [__] yeah Mena
apparently oh I am in Mena I got can you
want me to tell you that story I are
you're literally in Mena here's the
thing so when I got divorced I feel like
you strong armed everybody to let you
into don't make me get my horse boys
well it turns out it's a bunch of nerds
and I'm not one yeah I I just picture a
bunch of dorks being like he's not
leaving let's just say he's in doesn't
want to leave he wants to play the board
game handing out nuggies and
Squires I talk to your boss what wait
what is Mena by the way men it's like
the I don't listen he would yeah you
explain it's just a it's like a society
here's here's what it is you're a
society here's what it's build as it's
build as a so it's for geniuses but I I
have to tell you something that I think
it really is just they let a lot of
people in that they think are going to
pay the do okay that's my theory on did
you have to give like a resume like hey
I was a 2.3 and I got a 24 no you didn't
so I I went in I don't think you're in
me I went into therapy okay to get uh
obvious like when I was going through a
divorce and this guy had grown up seven
miles away from where I grew up but he
went to Duke University for 3 years and
when I got in there he was like well how
y'all doing and I'm like this isn't
going to work for me you picked up an
accent in three years and so he goes
sounds like you're a
between a rock and a hard place young
man and I'm like this is this your
therapist yeah and I'm like I I'm not
doing this you're like a fake person
sure you're lying about your accent I'm
not taking your your advice and then he
goes you I feel like you think that's a
pickle right there yes exactly devil in
the deep blue sea two shots of Mr Boston
can't deal with he's whittling wood as
you're telling him in a rocking chair so
he goes I think I feel like you think
you're the smartest person in the room a
lot of times and I go well for sure in
this room and then he said I would like
you to take a test I thought it was a
personality test and so he goes make an
appointment down in Minneapolis and I
was working at Acme Comedy Company one
week and so I go I'll take it on that
Sunday Vikes don't play no big deal okay
like most Geniuses so Vikes aren't
playing so I'm hammered that night I go
down still hung over take the test get
my results back I'm in Mensa no [__] I
promise you so then I go in and I go why
did you make me take this test and he
goes well because I wanted you to
realize you're the smartest person in
the room and to calm you down a little
bit and I put the results on his desk
and I go well what now [__] yeah what
about now Mr three years at Duke now
I'll tell you I bet you I take the test
again I I don't get in so what it said
you were a genius I don't know what it
was about it can we get the actual
definition of Mena do you have it I do
Mena means table in Latin and the organ
that's not what I
meant ah we have a society of tables
it's a Greek place on 34 Street a
furniture store and the organization was
so named because Mena is a Roundtable
Society where ethnicity color creed
national origin age politics and
educational and social background are
all completely irrelevant okay uh do you
want the criteria to get in yes let's
get some of that cuz it sounds like it's
a bunch of guys oh there are lots of
lots of females so they do every year
they have a thing where new board games
come out and you can go and you can go
to this Mena group and you can play the
board try them out I did it one time in
Austin Texas like Monopoly like board
games like that uh yeah I mean but new
ones that they're testing for Market
that's who they have do that yeah yeah
dorks dude what do you mean some fat kid
in a mall I I went down there and a a
real grown man had a teddy bear with him
and I'm like okay how do I get out of
Mena well apparently that teddy bear
wield and weirdo had an IQ above the
998th percentile that's how you have to
get in yes so you have an IQ above the
98th percentile that test I took it yeah
well [__] next patreon we're finding
out if we can get inmensa for sure oh
yes that's what we're doing that's
happening damn and then you have to take
the wonderl test which is the what they
give quarterbacks when they go into the
NFL I know yeah so you take a you take
an IQ test and then you take that test
right afterwards okay and that one's
hard because the first questions are
pretty easy but then they get harder and
harder you only have 15 minutes I think
15 minutes to take it but it was I
didn't what's the Wonder luck test
that's what they give quack problem
solving to make sure quarterbacks are
going to be able to read defenses and be
able to check the line when they get to
scrimmage that's pretty cool you didn't
know that no ex football star like
yourself no I didn't know that that's
pretty sweet yeah it's a contemporary
cognitive ability test that was created
in
1939 bet you Tom Brady did real good on
that I bet so too yeah see you can get a
score I'm sure it's up um that's wild K
let's talk about hellofresh hello fresh
top of the Year everyone's looking to
revamp their uh you know what they're
putting in their body eating habits do
yourself a favor go over to helloof
Fresh they can straighten your right
hellofresh is America's number one meal
kit they send pre portioned ingredients
they do to the house delicious recipes
and you do it so you get to feel like a
cook but you got everything right in
front of you everything's all portioned
out all that stuff throw it in the
skillet mix it up next thing you know
your girl thinks you're a uh
award-winning James Beard Chef sure uh
they have over 45 recipes and more than
100 seasonal add-on items to choose from
every week they'll keep finding new
meals to love it's Fant it's nice thing
for you and a lady or you and your man's
or whoever you and whatever cooking
together they cook together it's easy
peasy there's no like shopping list of
this and that I feel it's me and my bird
me me and the lady in the kitchen you
know you're doing it I'm yelling out
fire the bread sticks or whatever they
slip a cheesecake in there every once in
a while a Machi couple of times I got a
little cheesecake cup showed up
delicious uh hello fresh even as
breakfast you can make it a pinch and
fast 10minute lunches uh go to
hellofresh.com
garbage free and use code garbage free
for a free for free breakfast for life
oh my God one breakfast item per box
while your subscription is active that's
free breakfast for life at
hellofresh.com garbage free with code
garbage free hellofresh America's number
one meal kit do it this episode is
brought to you by a better help yes gang
January already sucks do yourself a
favor don't start making resolutions
that you can keep that are impossible to
keep too much pressure what you want to
do is you want to get started with
therapy through better help and learn to
celebrate yourself and not beat yourself
up don't spend time worrying about stuff
that you can't handle talk to somebody
yeah uh better help is entirely online
it's convenient flexible and suited to
your schedule whether you want to talk
to a therapist over video call by phone
by message whatever it is better help
makes it easy uh big fan of talk therapy
used it through many different parts of
my life as a kid they made me go this
guy's a real Looney Dr Jenkins can kick
rocks I'm
fine uh through how many chicken figures
do you think is too many uh you know
relationship stuff throughout my life
work stuff throughout my life comedy
it's been it's it's a great tool so if
you're thinking about starting therapy
definitely give better help a try it's
the easiest way to get in the pool you
thr from the privacy of your home you
don't go talk to some [__] bozo
somewhere par lot some bad office uh
celebrate the progress you've already
made visit betterhelp.com garbag toay to
get 10% off your first month that's
betterhelp
hp.com garbage do it gang do it all
right well I mean I didn't know you're
the first genius on the show Chad I
don't know that I am the first that you
are a genius I don't know that I'm a
genius I'm telling you I took this test
hung over you got the paperwork yeah
that's true I got the card did you stay
with the therapist or did you ice them I
iced him and why did three years at Duke
what's that mean he graduate well he
might he went down there that's what
they told me they go he went to Duke for
three years like I was going to be like
what he only passed two classes no [__]
that's some small town [__] right real
hillbilly
[__] he ate in the
cafeteria okay uh huh all right um let's
go back a little bit um so was you your
sister your sister was a little bit
younger what was the the the the
breakfast situation on school days
during the year when you were a little
kid what would you be getting would your
mom make uh or were you on your own if
they were both working kind of on your
own my mom was around to make sure that
we like had breakfast but it was it was
cereal with milk and then later on after
that it was cereal with powdered milk oh
we in the lean years yeah lean years
where at one point you just go [__] it
I'll just have water on it really just
to wash it down damn like a Hot Dog
Eating competition so you guys moved
into the new house and then financially
things went bad yeah yeah yeah so they
so poor people in an nice house exactly
my childhood baby ain't nothing more
American than that godamn it I learned
the word house po at 9 years old yeah we
were basically squatters for a while
really [__] okay man powdered milk I
don't know if I ever had that powdered
eggs I don't powdered eggs I don't hate
yeah will you eat at will you eat at the
the breakfast at a hotel in the morning
like like a holiday in not like not like
an ISO tuble you'll do like the you if
you have a wa waffle iron that flips
you're in you're sign CH up I can smell
it from my room you think I'm not going
to go use that thing I'm not going to
got two I got 2 minutes and 30 seconds
to
kill I'm TSA pre-check I'll be flight
those those shitty hotels man sometimes
they they surprise you you come down in
the morning this shit's all free ain't
too shabby I love them I just put the
the scrambled eggs I put uh some uh some
napkins down on the plate to absorb the
water that comes with them that's a road
dog Pro dud I used to so I used to carry
keys with me from different hotels the
key cards and so when I was on the road
if I was staying at one that didn't have
a continental breakfast I'd go to one
that did close to it and I'd you know
have my key with me just in case anybody
asked that's genius that's trash what
are you talking about I mean I'm in but
God damn you are no trash now now he got
an imensa when [__] power moves this
guy's been playing chess this whole time
he's turning Keys into coupons dude when
when I was hosting at the Mall of
America when the
other you can't get me to
stop first Menon now hosting at the Mall
of America
boom while the headliner was on I'd go
get in line at a fancy restaurant and
get one of those vibrating buzzer deals
mhm and then uh as soon as it would go
off I'd sell it to somebody that was way
back in line wa yeah it was like trying
to make money when you were just
starting you know you had to get free
breakfast you had to make a little extra
scratch I don't think anybody's ever
thought so You' go like hey Chad table
for four you you'd go yeah you'd go
probably table of six normally you go
six obviously and then you find somebody
back close to the line that has kids
that are getting restless and you go
what the [__] hey I gotta this this is
for a table of six right now you know 50
bucks if you want it make an extra 50 on
it no kidding you might be a genius
probably give the kids coffee too to get
them real ancy hey have some have some
candy some of my dad's cocaine walk by
snapping getting it in the air like
Anthrax [__] man playing hard ball with
a Midwest it's buzzing guys make a move
it's either you or the Jenkins or eting
tonight you got five minutes and the
whole party's got to be there let's go
wow that's diabolical very very smart I
like it and what about lunch at school
would you pack your lunch would you buy
your lunch there pack lunch pack lunch
mom make it you make it I'd make it the
night before that morning morning you
just kind of throw some stuff in there
okay what are we looking at uh whatever
was available lot of vanilla wafers a
lot of bugles
bugles that's a blast from the P you
know what a bugle
is exactly would you put them on your
fingers at lunch of course you got to
play Wicked
Witch and then I had a card trick that I
would do and I'd get people's lunch
money this guy a goddamn Hustler's
playing [__] three card Monty I bet
people their lunch money that they
couldn't uh whatever I could get their
card no [__] Jesus man any injuries as a
kid no never uhuh nothing not a one to
date it broken anything no I mean
sprained ankles here and there busted
ribs but I mean nothing crazy it's what
happens when you're a gypsy going down
yeah a Pit Boss broke his fingers one
time I got tuned up for cing cars in
Vegas what of it I've been run out on a
rail a couple of
towns all right folks I got to
go puts a briefcase under his
arm
man this took a
turn like
it doing C tricks a lunch for
money selling fake mortgages in high
school
okay so where'd you guys go after did
you how long did you guys stay in the in
the big house and it was just you your
sister and your mom we kicked out cuz my
dad left my mom in bankruptcy okay and
then we went to an apartment okay and
then when you say he finally dip dipped
he like out of your life dipped that
left the town no nine blocks away get
the [__] out of here and saw him maybe
every seven months no [__] yeah was so
it was like he was gone but he just he
was lingering yeah so until until the
divorce is it a normal Mom Dad
everybody's loving you never you never
saw this coming and then all of a sudden
he's when you look back when you were
like five when I look back at 5 years
old it was rough you saw it coming I
mean my old man would gamble on payday
and he would either come home with crab
legs or chicken Chowan in a can and when
he came home with chicken chowa in a can
we knew he lost yeah and my sister and I
would be like all right we'll be outside
yeah we go Jesus but you guys were close
my sister and I yeah still no but but
with your dad like he was loving towards
you guys and all you guys and then just
just not my so both parents loved us we
loved them they didn't love each other I
don't think so a lot of talking through
the kids a lot of dinner table like can
you tell your father to stop chewing so
loudly and it's like do you mean the one
right here who ouch that kind of stuff
but then nine blocks away you see him
once every seven months yeah about You'
never just go over to his house say hey
what's going on didn't want to show up
didn't know it was going to happen H was
he living there by himself well yeah but
we did it we went over there one time
just to say like hey want want to hang
out and watch some TV and there were
like melted candles on the table that
were melted all the way down and like
pouring over the tables got so it was a
[__] Shack yeah all right or he's a
vampire you don't want to walk in on
yeah or yeah that's true he's dead so
that kind of kills that theory he's not
a vampire but it wasn't a garlic
accident so who knows yeah yeah it was
well I'd like to look at you got very
vampire Hunter vibes
this could this could be a whole thing
what that's what I'm looking
for day
Walker huh who would baby S as a kid
family me you would yeah well how long
did well I guess from probably seven on
I would walk seven dude him at a SE
imagine him at 7even he's probably more
mature than me and you at the right now
he's wearing that exact
outfit he's yawn at his sister to go to
bed and the door and when you come back
bring us
food they'd leave you seven and your
sister was two y so you're watching her
y changing her diaper and stuff like
that y
damn what was your first job paper boy
okay all right yeah what was the what
was what were you riding around on was
the wh skateboard skateboard yeah I'd
use a skateboard sometimes I'd have to
pull it cuz there was gravel sometimes
I'd have to you know sling the bag over
hold on to the skateboard what would you
do in the winter walk really yeah you
had to walk that had to suck it sucked
bad how bad were the was the were the
winners there uh so I don't know they
get 30 40 below zero but then sometimes
that's not that bad sometimes you get a
polar vortex and it's 70 below zero with
windchill [__] that and you moved back
there after you got out where did you
move to after miniapolis I've never
lived anywhere but Minnesota okay huh
man that is wild what was the pet
situation grew up with dogs dogs indoor
dogs outdoor dogs indoor only yeah what
kind of what breed we have had a mut for
the first one that was Mogan and then we
had an apricot poodle named
Jack and then we had I think another mut
named Cole black dog was the apricot
poodle in the good
years in the in the in the Good
Financial years yeah but towards the end
like it was almost like that dog could
sense it too cuz it started getting
bumps all over its body it's like I'm
out of here
this I don't know if you guys see the
writing on the wall here but wait did
you keep them all until they until they
pass or they run away kept them all kept
them all yep all right still got them uh
huh huh interesting I feel like you guys
are trying to solve a crime we are I
love it we are and you for sure did
it gy who just haven't connected the
dots I feel like I'm on for First 48
right
now this is like mind Hunter uh okay huh
what was the poster situation uh in the
room as a kid you had your own room I
had my own room Y and in the big house
well I guess I had my own room the whole
time okay but uh so you know in the big
house it was probably Michael Jordan
sure stuff like that respect it uh had
throwing stars I would throw throwing
stars at the posters you you were
throwing Chinese stars in your room in
my room which F guess what you take
those posters down holes behind them of
course but good thing uh the bank took
the house back we didn't have to sell it
no big deal about the holes yeah punch
holes in the walls never punched never
punched just Chinese stars y okay H wow
got those flea market of course you did
where else do you get Chinese unless you
went to the Far East at a young age but
you didn't have a
passport want you get some Chinese
throwing stars and some spices we think
you got him at Blooming
Dales got I'm just chucking them and
then cinnamon in my mouth yeah Daddy
likes it BB Gun BB Gun yep got it for
Christmas I got in trouble for baiting
crows in the backyard or uh blackbirds I
guess what's baiting mean baiting means
like you put bread out and when they
come eat it TK chk really yeah you got
some bodies on you yeah you would look
at pretty decent count dude pretty
decent count [__] throwing crab legs
in the backyard do you hunt now or
anything like that I don't I've never
hunted other than that with a BB gun you
got any nickel at the house uh no pieces
uhuh Minnesota no piece just talked
about that too cuz we got uh you seem
like a tactical gun guy too I'm I love
shooting them but I just I don't think I
should have one at the house yeah he is
a bit of a Loose Cannon and apparently
so the United States
government FBI can't tell me what to do
FBI W
bu okay all right you do seem like a guy
who could unassemble and reassemble a
gun blindfolded and I you look like the
guy Matt Damon plays in the movie you
look like the real guy black and white
photos of you and him on
set and you're showing them how to [__]
you're showing them how to sweep a
room
is he wearing cargo pants I
don't very sharp guy though very but
masculine compared to me in him this got
lost but did did you go to college I
went to three years at a community
college some call it Duke Mana uh yeah
three years at a community college just
didn't take I was just there for the
social aspect of it okay and where were
you living at home or did you get your
own place got my own place you got your
own place well with I mean roommates
roommates okay so your mom and your
sister are in the apartment cuz your
sister's younger than you she's probably
in high school at this point like we
just lived in the apartment for one year
okay my mom so think about my old man
how shitty my mom is that great on the
other end of the spectrum so she got
through bankruptcy got an apartment for
one year and then found someone that
would sell their house I can't remember
what it's called like rent to deed maybe
something like sure yeah like one of
those and so you basically you're
renting until you prove you can take
over the mortgage okay and so it got us
a house one year later so from 10th
grade to senior year for me I was in a
house okay and then when I went to
school in the same town my sister and
Mom were at that house okay gotcha damn
Hustler okay yeah for real love that any
trouble in high school arrested anything
like that yeah I got arrested uh I took
um Advance chemistry class because I
thought to myself everyone in here wants
good grades so I knew if I didn't do my
homework they would do it if I was their
partner they would finish the project
because they didn't want to get a bad
grade and so I'm like I'm just going to
[__] ride coattails that's a felony
in your town what the hell so then that
you catch in a case so then I learned
how to break I bought a lot of
fertilizer I learned I try was I was
trying to rent a
truck oh man he does this guy's got bite
bomb written all over
him holy [__] all right so okay so hold
on so chemistry class
so they taught us how to break an
electrical circuit with San Jesus
[Laughter]
Christ all right okay they tell you how
to break what an electrical circuit with
saline solution okay and then I noticed
the the security of the local chemical
plant was a little LAX D I'm telling you
kind
of go ahead so I'm watching this light
bulb go on and off in class and I go go
oh yeah the ATM will do that and so I go
home and I make this saline solution
which is just saltwater and then I go
and I'm uh at my buddy's house and I go
I'm going to go do this at the ATM see
if I can break the circuits have all the
money come out what grade's this this is
you are a [__] genius I'm a junior
I'm a junior crazy and then my buddy
goes oh you'll go to jail it doesn't
matter if you're 17 if you do an ATM
it's the bank so you'll go to jail
forever so you killed
him got tie up loose ends and I was like
just look at this butter knife
quick and so uh Chinese star Just Hits
it
right say you washing your hands I did
have a Mr Boston blowdart gun so we uh
we he talked me into trying it on pop
machine soda machines first okay and so
we did that broke 13 of them got caught
and was it working could you access them
what happens is you you put it in the
dollar changer you spray it in the
dollar changer everything shuts down and
then all the quarters come out and if
you push the button for Coke or
sun-kissed or whatever all of that EMP
what [__] now by the way do not do this
of course of course the goddamn 90s
right so uh big haul lot of lot of soda
cans so what you do with were you going
to try to move that well no we were just
going to you got a guy in the bed so you
hit 13 you got
connect hold on hey Dad you need some
mixers yeah so your buddy went from
trying to convince you not to do it now
he's an accessory yeah that's right you
guys do it together but it's just soda
machine you hit 13 soda machines which
also is a felony cuz it's too many okay
and did they tell you the number of what
wouldn't have been the felony if you
were like hey it was a dollar Mount I
can't remember the math on one Dr Pepper
over the line baby what was the what was
the hall I mean just a back seat full of
soda cans and then you know were you
laughing a lot I would have been dying
laughing we were just like it's working
again I would still be on that a tear
doing that you you know the noise that
the dollar bill uh receiver makes when
you put it in go yeah that it would make
that noise when the circuits would start
to break so anytime we heard that noise
we were like oh my God yes and just dump
it would just start Dum and it would
just start dumping and how much a couple
hundred bucks thousands of dollars no no
no may maybe 200 maybe and then you got
pinched we got pinched my small town so
my little league coach who's a cop
pulled us over and I was like can't get
a damn drop of Pepsi in this whole
goddamn Town what the hell's going on
whole County's
dry yeah so I was like hey coach how's
it going is this after a job this is
like after you guys had just done one or
is we did all in one night all 13 one
one night Nightfall yeah so he just like
does the you know did you dress up in
like all black and stuff like that oh
you would think you would think but my
[__] friend who Dred me out of you're
wearing your little league Jersey he
actually he's wearing his foot high
school football jersey oh my God so
somebody sees the number so even if we
get away with it we're [__] yeah the
next day and so um we get and we're in
the Cop Shop we're arguing about I'm
like I can't believe you wore that
goddamn Jersey goes you wanted to do an
ATM machine I'm like that's fair you us
I think it's a federal it's a federal
crime sure so when did he get you the
next night that night that night oh you
got caught that night that same you
stink you even get away with it for a
little while the guy had his name on his
back I know that's crazy so they pull
you over yeah pull us over and uh for
the
record the police car had a headlight
out which is also illegal sure that's
true so we D try to barter with them
like a sixpack is Fright you guys did a
crime we did a crime that kind of thing
but uh end up uh mowing a lot of church
Lawns community service community
service and then had to pay restitution
on all the all the pop Machines man so
he never got to the M huh no thank God
man yeah that seriously would have been
brutal yeah I might still be in
prison yeah cuz you killed people when
you got
there started running a gang whoa Mr
Daniels all right that's amazing that is
what are the numbers saying so far fill
me in not
great any any any involvement in uh
Student Activities uh student council
did you run for anything student council
was vice president of the class going up
really okay I feel a puppet regime he
was really pulling the strings I feel
put a figure head in there I'm I'm going
to not put my name on this prom but I
will be running
it bunch of Kickbacks and no show jobs
holy [__] okay huh all right when was
the first time you had
Nutella I mean maybe 30s okay okay this
is all checking out yeah who was the
doctor when you were a kid who was your
pediatrician m
Sanderson maybe okay Dr Sanderson the
name was that in his hat of his house or
was it in like a professional a clinic
clinic yeah okay Clinic situation I grew
up right across from a clinic and so
then when we moved across town it was
you know same deal what was uh what was
the name of the supermarket growing up
we had service food and more
four one of those sound good oh yeah
those are local the one sounds like
changes a lot of can chow yikes H how
was your mom in the kitchen good cook
fair fair fair to partly cloudy would
you guys have dinner together most times
yeah most times I mean when when I was a
teenager I was gone all the time I
didn't want to be home anyways my mom's
like you know get home from work
watching Days of Our Lives ripping
heaters mom ripping heaters yeah so I
you know you walk out and everybody's
like oh when didd you start smoking sure
well I don't but uh so I was gone a lot
what was her brand if do you recall o
Salem
check out whoa okay Days of Our Lives in
Salems I'm with you H okay well maybe
I'm thinking Salem because Days of Our
Lives takes place in Salem does does
take place in Salem oh maybe maybe
Salem's a okay maybe it is course
Salem's watching Salem she was trying to
get in the character uh what kind of
what were the family cars growing up uh
I had uh real long green Pontiac I don't
know what kind it was that's when I was
younger and then my dad came home
without ask asking my mom Mazda 626
brand new off the lot okay off the lot
your dad played it fast at loose off the
lot real trashy ter and then we had a uh
in Minnesota too that's so unpractical
it's like like a sports car yeah was
ridiculous and then we had a uh not a
Dodge Omni but whatever the other
version is like the the what was the
Dodge the Ripoff ver uh Plymouth Horizon
oh I know what you're talking about so a
little green Plymouth Horizon that's
what my mom had to drive after the you
know getting left that's what she was
zipping around in and then I I total
that car pouth r you total that car I
total that car cuz I went out uh to a
vending machine job a cabin a lay cabin
with these with these girls and a buddy
of mine and then I use my mom's
sunglasses and she goes you always lose
my sunglasses do not lose these
sunglasses I'm like all right so I
forgot them so we had to go back and
there's a little hair pin turn on this
gravel road and in my head I had already
passed it cuz I did once so I was
driving way too fast and we rolled into
an Al Alpha field damn yeah shattered it
up real good Al Alpha field what the
[__] an alphalpha field what is Al
field where they grow alphalpha grass
it's like uh it's actually really good
[__] all a sudden what the [__] you
do turn on me [__] I actually like
I'm sorry I like it on a sandwich too to
be honest with you like anything on a
sand I think ever had it okay it's like
the fancy Sprouts they put on sandwiches
Sprout could have said a sprout
field
okay [__]
Mena [__] jamming me up over here all
right all right so that's the childhood
I mean you are I think you are kind of
one you are a oneof one character I feel
does that make
sense no okay only see I but I don't get
one of one character you're like uh I
mean we've been doing this a lot you're
unique you're a unique character I got
you okay did not like that no no no I do
I what I'm thinking speak of is is you
say that's the childhood so I mean my
old man dude this guy stole my identity
ruined my credit we had a lot of stuff
what age did he steal your identity I
was
maybe 15 hey with social security card
to open something up or social security
number got an apartment electric phone
no [__] loans stuff like that so then
when I was older I went to get stuff and
I was like there go you had no idea uh
if you didn't even find out when it was
failing you found out way I found a try
to get trying to get a car loan and they
were like like nice try dude damn [__]
so he stole your identity and then rang
up a bunch of bills and didn't pay them
right and he was still alive still alive
at that point any conversation with him
about that no no nothing you don't call
him and say yo what the hell no whoa my
mom cuz when when I find out about it I
don't know where he is gotcha and then
my mom has to write a bunch of these
letters to a bunch of people to say like
he was living with me the whole time
this wasn't him Jesus I assure you my
son owns no boats let alone
for uh yeah what was the stuff was it
just an apartment yeah just like normal
living stuff okay nothing nothing too
elaborate what's your sister do now she
is a a a psych nurse and a a surge Tech
okay so does two different things in two
different hospitals and is she out there
in Minnesota too yeah she lives uh close
to duth Minnesota okay all
right okay huh anyone in your family
ever get married at the
courthouse I don't think so okay here we
go things are looking out starting to
turn a little bit what's the house
situation now so you you were married
you had kids you and your wife got got
divorced yep and then you moved away and
then moved back nope I stayed put okay
so my my ex-wife and I were eight blocks
away from each other just for the kids
to for ease of that okay still so I have
that house still okay my son rents it
okay your son's an adult now yep 24 and
then I moved down to Minneapolis and
bought a different house okay okay and
then you also have the lake house yes
three houses it's too much I know that's
great almost a billion streams the guy's
doing all right yeah this might pull you
out of this can't I can't wait to get
out of this third house deal what the
the old one the one that my son rents
rented deed get I'm going to try to get
him to buy it yeah yeah smart what's he
doing now uh coating coating coating and
growing weed nice yeah cuz I think
historically in your bits he's you all
you've always painted him as a bit of a
a dummy a a little bit well yeah just
somebody who just the common sense
wasn't always there sure not men but I
mean it's like the teen I'm painting him
as a teenage boy really of course yeah
yeah so um but yeah he man he got it
together he was like I'm not going to
play video games I'm going to start
making video games and I was like prove
it and then he then he did so okay
that's [__] awesome yeah I'm pretty
jazzed up for him so you're down in
Minneapolis now uh Suburban House
Suburban House Suburban House how many
bedrooms four four bedroom house down
there not bad you got Garage on that
thing got a three car garage what the
hello attached or detached attached very
nice what are you whipping around town
in what are you driving now uh Chevy
Traverse that's what I drive Chevy
Traverse can you park three cars in that
garage yes so it's clean enough
organized enough well ye yes but it I
mean you could really really walk around
in there if I would do a little bit of
stuff okay got in between the cars there
is a layer of [__] we haven't brought
into the house yet okay what's the back
yard situation uh so we're on a hill and
so we have a little bit of a backyard
it's tiered okay and then it goes off
into uh we have a fence and then it goes
off into a slooh area what's a slooh
like a a Marsh Marsh is it nice like a
like a dirty Pond okay yeah all right
yeah okay freezes over in the winter
right it does it's already yeah frozen
over right now on it I wish you could
but there's like Cattails and stuff so
you would get jammed up a little bit I
was thinking about bringing like one of
those maybe just a lawn mower out there
and getting it low enough and then
spraying more water on it got to mow
your ice yeah I mean I don't mind you
still play hockey I got I got a hip
replacement oh [__] and so if I fall
down and it breaks I'm in deep [__] huh
hip replacement yeah any hot tubs in any
of those homes I have a hot tub in the
Minneapolis home Standalone hot tub
stand alone outside outside yeah really
can you use it in the winter oh yeah
really yeah oo just keep it warm enough
you making payments on that or did you
pay pay up front for the house hot tub
hot tub came with the house came with
the house yeah so technically I am
making payments on the hot sure okay all
right I like it have you ever got
anything from Rena Center of course yeah
really ice cream maker for graduation
parties uh cotton candy maker it doesn't
count yeah we were talking like you ever
rent a couch for two years rent a couch
no never if you had the ice cream maker
just in the house on a Wednesday that
would be yeah hey would be crazy kids
want
vanilla huh ever been to a monster truck
rally uh-uh huh will you send stuff back
at a restaurant what's the criteria
there if uh yeah I mean if it's not what
I order sometimes I'll just get up and
leave if it's not what I order I'm not
going I'm not going to take I'm not
going to send it back all right hold on
a second let's take a step back all
right he's a no no fuss no Guff guy you
go out to dinner okay all right you're
sitting down you've gotten your
appetizers or whatever Y and then then
you ordered um I don't know bacon
cheeseburger okay and they come over
with a half roasted chicken mhm you're
not going to say anything you're just
going to get up and leave in that
situation I'd be like I don't think this
is mine but I'm going to I'll give you a
specific situation original original
House of
Pancakes Spokan Washington and this is
not alleged this happened I can prove it
okay went in there and Kelsey and I are
trying to get uh some some food and she
can't have deer
this is recent yeah so she's like uh hey
uh you know can you make the stuff with
butter and this guy goes uh or without
butter with oil and he goes no no no we
only cook stuff in butter and I go I
don't think that's right yeah you got o
back there he goes no no no I mean we
cook everything in but but it's
clarified butter does that count and I
go do you hear yourself saying butter
still so that's that's butter sure and
then we leave we didn't order anything
and we leave and I go back to next day
she has a haircut and I'm like I'm going
to get this waffle that I've been
dreaming about cuz they have what I
think is the greatest waffle in the
history man nice WAFF fresh sliced
strawberries homemade whipped cream so I
go in and I go I want that really fluffy
waffle with the Fret blah blah blah this
dude brings me a waffle meal with an ego
that I just I look at him and I break it
right in front of him and I go what the
[__] is this and then I set it down and
then I excuse myself psycho I'm not a
psycho bring me the [__] I mean that's
crazy that's two days CH it was the same
server from the day before oh man you
had chip on had out for you you get you
get one shot this guy had no idea how
close he getting his throat
slit this guy was a bad baked potato
away from
disappearance okay huh all right um
split the check if you go out with like
another
couple that's hard for me yeah why I I
don't know what it is about it I got
like I got something in me where I where
if they let it sit for a second I'll
grab for you'll grab the same way okay I
respect that no Veno requests anything
like that grab it it's just like you
know and then and then you kind of wait
for we'll get it next time or whatever
sure respect gentleman's move that's the
gentleman's move I'll give you that is
there current currently any milk crates
in that house in
Minneapolis
oo but plastic you mean like yeah I
think maybe for for U moving pictures I
think I have it's just you in the house
right there no
Kelsey but no kids no kids right okay
kids are older right they're out of the
house okay what's the vacuum situation
at the house you got a Dyson one no one
vacuum it's a shark I think we got a
shark okay yeah shark we uh you know run
it over we got two cats and a dog so we
have that whatever the pet version of
that is okay I got one myself not too
shabby have you ever taken a bath at a
hotel I've taken a uh when they have the
hot tub situation like the bubble
whatever the Jacuzzi Jacuzzi room I've
taken those okay I respect that H will
you eat in the hotel room will I eat
yeah have a full meal in the hotel room
yeah use the ironing board as a as a as
a table I'll right on my lap I'll I'll
grab a pillow I'm not using okay and
then prop it up that's after it yeah you
have a brand of hotel that you really
enjoy on the road if you can stay at one
you know I'm just like I like a
Marriott like a courtyard just because
then it uh you know it's the same stuff
know what you're getting absolutely know
what you're getting okay napkin on your
shirt when you eat
ever yeah tucked in yeah probably when
I'm eating a crab or something really
okay will you will you will you swim at
the pool Courtyard Marriott will you
take a dip in the pool in the hot tub
sure absolutely okay gentlemen any
nicknames growing up buzz and then any
rendition of Chad you can think of Chad
or Chadwick sure who called you a buzz
my mom
okay buzz you know how to use chopsticks
I do okay have you had raisins in the
last 365 days absolutely you have oh
yeah why I don't know I like them you
like ra car into a raisin
field this guy's Cal eat his way out
chocolate covered yogurt covered no you
got raisins in your house Raisins and
Almonds yeah ah and a trail mix no it's
just a bag of almonds bag of uh raisins
you have just a plain bag of raisins in
your house myself
uh oh what's happening I feel like I'm
I'm losing cold shiver got a cold shiver
up my spine uh are you on the hooch you
drinking at the moment I drink sometimes
yeah you have a cocktail at the house uh
not really I don't often but we just had
a party where I had way too much okay
what's the go-to drink if you're if
you're indulging maybe just like a you
know vodka soda I do like a tequila on
the Rocks though okay you got booze at
the house yep nice you have a bar area
set up uh it's kind of a one of those
like little miniature Hutch bars that we
have in our dining room I like it okay
um just had a party had a holiday party
yeah okay December 30th December 30th
just because comedians you know a lot of
times they're working sure on 31st so we
decided to have it on the 30th pot lock
or did you guys uh put the spread out so
what I said we put most of the spread
out bought all the booze and I said if
you're proud of or have any sort of
nostalgic uh dessert that you that you
want to bring to show it off it's
welcome don't need to okay I like that I
like that too nice cuz people have pride
in it like you said like they're like I
want to make my whatever I would even
stretch that from desserts like if you
have a killer chick buffalo chicken
appetizers too oh that's nice that's a
great way to throw the gauntlet down too
yes it really is like bring your [__]
aame bring your [__] a game put a
little passion into it you're only
making it cuz you want to not cuz you
have to and what did you guys what did
you guys put out for the guest was it a
full dinner we put out no not a full
dinner
tons of
bugles we had lot of
raisins just Raisins and
Almonds dig in everybody the [__] people
in the corner what the [__] we had like
uh you know a guac chip salsa queso
situation Kelsey made her Grandma's
famous spicy mustard and then I popped
some Bavarian pretzels in the oven and
had that kind of stuff sound that that M
all right you got a foosball table at
the house I presume had to yeah yeah
that was that was a thank you for moving
to Minnesota gift sure anything else you
got a bumper pool table anything
anything down there p uh we have a ping
pong and we have a dartboard okay all in
the basement right all in the basement
okay very that's that's a fun basement
right there yeah it's a fun little game
room good basement and where are you
shopping now at the at the house where
where's your where's your grocery store
that you go to in Minneapolis there's a
place called luns and blees luns sounds
fancy that we fre it is a little fancy
but it's got all the brands you would
think it's got you know it's not like
Foods where you go in there and it's
like you you have to get their brand or
some weird ass brand you've never heard
of I mean you're going into London Bley
and you're getting chips aoy Doritos
that's all I need whatever you need I'm
in but then they also have their little
floofy sections whatever sure and are
you eating chips aoy and stuff like that
at the house I'll have uh if we came
over right now what's can we come over
yes absolutely if you you guys have an
appetizer or dessert that you're proud
of get the hugie dip go ahead and bring
it what snacks would you offer us if we
were we were stay we were at the house
right now oh oh man probably a do you
have chips aoy no I bet I bet there are
some Oreos though cuz before before New
Year's Eve I was making uh chocolate
covered oreos and then I said that I was
going to try to not eat sugar for a
while you know that deal chocolate
covered oreos you making for the party
no just for myself just for yourself
yeah I I mean I take a big you taking
them to the Head a glob of chocolate and
dump it on I don't try to make it look
nice anything like that and then just as
soon as it's cooled get it right you're
eating them right away yeah
okay what if we came over H and I asked
for a water what would I get would I get
a bottle of water do you have it out of
the filter you get a glass of water
there's like this reverse osmosis is
that what you have system you have a
reverse osmosis where you have the
little skinny the little skinny faucet
next to the main faucet okay you'd get
something out of there that's pretty
good that's pretty good yeah that's not
bad fridge uh double-sided open like
that uh no the fridge is uh it's two
doors but it's top is the refrigerator
bottom is the freezer and then the
bottom has like an ice tray that makes
its own ice okay and then there's two
long drawers and another skinny drawer
next to the ice machine okay when you
guys are home will you guys have dinner
together will you sit at the table we
sit at the kitchen island yeah sit at
the kitchen island we don't have a
dining room table yet no dining room
table yet will you sit in front of the
TV and watch TV and have dinner is that
something that can happen I can but we
have pets that love to be near us and so
that's a lot so we just we keep it on
the high top they can they can that all
makes sense um do you have a go-to
karaoke
song and do you do karaoke I suppose I
do karaoke so I mean when it's called
for I'm I'm never like we should we
should go do karaoke I'm not that guy
but if we find ourselves there I like a
rock this town by the Stray Cats okay
Rock This Town rock it inside out yeah
that's right that's a good one your
first
concert that's a great question CU we're
about the same age first concert may
have been a a triple header where it was
uh um Bush no doubt and uh goooo dolls
whoa at the Fargo Dome that's pretty
good but I was Fargo 19 it was 19 or 20
something like that that's a good first
concert I know yeah 19 or 20 I didn't go
I didn't uh we didn't have the stuff to
get there um do you like your bun
toasted if you have a burger do you like
like your bun toasted so when I'm at the
lakeh house I will toast it on a flat
top I'll butter it with well I'll put
mayonnaise on it okay and then I'll I'll
toast it on that but I don't need it
toasted in any situation is this an
outdoor flat top that you have outdoor Y
what other what other grilling equipment
do you have out there I have a normal
gas grill and then I have a smoker
Trager
yep how are you how are you on the flat
top people come by you can do a whole
breakfast you got the hash BRS going
breakfast we're big fajita people that's
at the lake place never heard that said
in my life just cuz all I don't know if
you know about us out here we're big
fajita people yeah they call us a Sizzle
gang basically dump a bucket of it on
the flat top and let her rip I mean it's
so easy okay it's so easy any ATVs or
anything out there at the lake house
nope canoe uh I have a pontoon boat you
got a pontoon why do you say something I
got a jet ski how big you got a jet ski
yeah 22 22 footer that's a big that's a
nice ponon Bo you got the bathroom on it
pop-up bathroom or no uhuh we had a lake
sure that's the bathroom pontoon boat
and a jet ski's got three
houses okay any uh obviously I am I am
tumbling towards
bankruptcy just like your
dad uh it's all in the kid's name who
gives he's never going to get approved
never going to get approved to buy my I
was going to ask you guys what are your
middle
names uh obvious so you were married so
you were a little constricted but
anytime when you started making money
was there any stupid purchase or you
look back of like I didn't need that
your first big check you had kids and
got married younger so a little I don't
think so well here's the thing I didn't
start making money till all I mean it
was like the day it was almost like I
signed the divorce papers and then I got
a text that was like your album is going
crazy right now [__] and then the the uh
royalties started coming in I'm like
what the [__] I mean by every house you
see right after yeah holy [__] so you
did it you just you just did
yeah the
lakeer and then every time I see my ex's
family I'm like I don't know either I
don't know what happened I don't know
why it happened the way it did damn I I
got a couple more here okay mayonnaise
what's the mayonnaise situation helmond
or Miracle
Whip that's that Helman all right thank
God Jesus going to freak out um [__] the
it in the in the bedroom KingSize
mattress KingSize mattress KingSize
mattress TV in the bedroom no no TV in
the bedroom ceiling
fan yes don't use it though don't use it
right any fan on you when you sleep no
but uh uh What uh air fresh or air
purifier for White Noise gentle I have
tenus in my my ears so if if I sit there
and silence it is the proper way it's
pronounced by the way I mean it's crazy
okay so I've asked Kelsey before I'm
like can you hear this coming out of my
ears and she like puts her ear next to
my ear and she's like I can't hear
anything like think it's coming out of I
mean it's that it's that loud man it's
that loud that does make sense well let
me get my ear next to your ear and see
if it's heing what your ear is hearing
that's pretty good that's weird that you
think if you could hear it in her ears
next to your ear she should be able to
hear it she's like no I don't hear it
but I do hear the Wisconsin Dells call
my
name um huh how many pillows you
sleeping with uh I sleep with one under
okay then sometime when I'm by myself I
sleep with a under the arm on the side
yeah little little uh fake mate and what
are you sleeping in boxers boxers no
pajamas nothing like that are you a robe
guy I have a robe I use it very rarely
slippers uh no I use like a uh lined
Crocs okay all right fair enough mhm
you're taking the shoes off in the house
yes shoes are off in the house when you
come in that's mandatory that's not my
rule yep who shoveling the uh the
driveway you have somebody that does it
or you doing it so I do it on a light
day if I'm not home there is a guy that
comes by and it costs I can't remember
25 bucks or something what's a light day
out there does it still get heavy snow
like it like did when we were kids I
mean it will but we haven't had it yet
okay so I just bring the shovel out take
a couple passes and what do we what's a
heavy snow 3 feet four feet I mean just
anything where you have to shovel just
that area like you put the shovel in and
you immediately have to throw it over
your shoulder right calling a big G what
you calling the who's cutting the grass
you cutting the grass in the summer I I
don't know yet because we bought at the
end of summer and I did not cut the
grass okay so it's pretty Shaggy we're
going to have to figure that out it's
all right okay you peeing in the shower
I pee in the shower yeah brush your
teeth in there nope you make the bed in
the morning I pull the comforter up pull
the comforter up so it it's you know
like a fake make sure you ever write in
the book at a hotel like we were here
and we had a great time at like a bed
and breakfast or anything like that no
no okay it's evidence yeah you think he
want a paper trail [__] I'm paying with
cash dude what do you think I'm doing if
he did he's leaving the dates of the
crime will you get cash back when when
you go and make a purchase at like CVS
or something like that will you get like
hey give me 20 bucks never use the uh
safe I don't even know what you use cash
for anymore so I would never have how
much you got on you right now maybe 30
bucks 30 bucks pretty good what cards
are you throwing around you got an AMX
two I got two I got a business and then
I got a normal okay just cuz they get me
miles you know that goes when you're
traveling like Delta Delta man Delta MX
I do yeah two of them yeah Cheers Cheers
gentlemen shout out to the Delta credit
scores good uh it was very good and then
I didn't so I had to I bought nine
houses I I got my car broken into when I
moved to Minneapolis they stole my
checkbook so I had to change my account
and then I a couple of accounts a couple
of bills that I needed to switch I
didn't GM was one of them so so I lease
and I missed I can't remember it was
like 72 days late or something and
that's a big ding that's a real big ding
sucks um [__] I had one will you wash
your shoes in the washing
machine no okay well you doing with a
checkbook in your
car writing checks no no no I don't I
can't remember why I had it because we
were moving down and I think that I just
left it in there cuz I there were
certain things that I just grabbed a
thing you don't a box yeah yeah Loosely
and threw it into into the passenger
seat do you have a working printer in
that house no no you cross your sevens
no can you WR in cursive yes okay what's
the air fresher in the car at the moment
no air fresher gives me a headache okay
any time share pitches have you ever
been to a time share pitch I have one
time in Mexico we got a $250 gift card
or something for one of the restaurants
okay now what you sell that for 350
you know me well kids moving you wash
your hair uh every time you shower uh-uh
was told that's bad it's bad what are
you using in the shower using a bar
using uh soap use the shower I use uh
the I can't remember the brand shower
gel yeah bare skin or loofah I use a
washcloth use a wash cloth I go through
those quite a bit cuz I wash my [__]
last and then those pile up wash a new
washcloth every time new washcloth new
washcloth every shower well I wash my
[__] I just told you I can't be
spreading that around that rinses off
yeah yeah that's come on no I don't
think I
will look at you that's that's pretty
classy how many times we use a towel
forever I mean until until it makes me
smell like a wet dog yeah it's tough I'm
the same way how do you like your eggs
cooked over medium over medium mhm have
you ever been to a Harlem Globe trods
game no okay do you own a police scanner
no do you know how to tie a tie yes how
many suits do you own probably a couple
I'm gonna say
two that one is a little too small for
me and one's a little too big for me
okay but I so I don't think I could wear
them and look good okay but I have two
of them that are kind who's a designer
on them
suits oh man what's the uh anybody speci
yeah there is there's a store at The
Mall of America that sells these godamn
suits what start throwing some out $800
suits Armani no that's way too big for
you're talking to the guys I mean Hugo
Boss yeah Hugo Boss that's who it is
there you go guy who doesn't own a suit
got it such a stab in the dark cannot
believe I hit that that's amazing all
the silverware matches at the house
right you have one complete set we have
well yes but we've also brought from
different places so there it's a hodge
podge okay you don't have good
silverware that you keep we don't like
in a wooden box no in a wooden box have
you ever saved a Crown Royal bag younger
when I was younger when I was bartending
yeah any empty cigar boxes in your house
at the moment for storage no okay if you
have have a sandwich from a deli will
you dump the chips onto the paper or eat
the chips out of the
bag o that's a good one probably dump it
out dump it
out
okay I mean yeah he's trash yeah yeah
whoa I love
him thought he was going to hit me any
magazines in the bathroom when I said
pontoon I thought I thought I lost it
all it almost pulled you out what I
don't know he's got three hous he's do
guy does
well what are you yelling at me for I
know magazin in the bathroom I don't
think so a Pon tumba the the funnest
boat which makes it TR it's only you
can't water Pete Lee can't water ski
behind that thing you know what I mean
it's only to get drunk on the water
pretty much yeah you take it out of the
water in the winter I do you have to
yeah in the driveway was this in the
driveway I have somebody store it I
don't know how to do that stuff okay
yeah I got to winterize it winterize it
have you ever drank on the boat not
while it was in the water
oh I've drank on a boat not in the water
but but not but not mine but not mine no
guy's trash I don't know what to tell
you gang's got a brand new special out
on YouTube right now mixed reviews I am
telling you right now if you don't know
he is one of the absolute Killers
roaming the countryside so do yourself a
favor check them out Mr Chad Daniels
everybody thanks for having me% track
love it appreciate it I'll wear it with
honor such a good one anything else you
want the folks out there to know you got
coming up PL social websit yeah I got
that Chad Daniels on social media I got
uh temp tempy coming up and uh
Springfield Missouri Oklahoma City and
I'm taping another special March 2nd in
St Paul Minnesota there you go absolute
killer if you haven't seen him you got
to go see them Kippy what do you got for
them uh we uh you can get your ayg card
game at rug garbage.com and also pick up
tickets to Town Hall New York City
Thursday May 9th tickets are going quick
get them let's party biggest show we've
ever done we appreciate it yeah bring
the squad and command Chad thank you
again buddy we love boys we love you and
gang we love you and we'll see you next
week peace peace